there was once a plan to change Paris
forever
large parts of the historic Center
destroyed and in its place buildings
that touched the sky and served as the
headquarters for the French Elite
it was the master plan of one of the
most influential architects of the 20th
century
as much a man who wanted to design
buildings as one who wanted absolute
power and to see his vision for
essentially controlled hierarchical
Society come to life
from the 1920s to the 1930s paris's
population grew from four to five
million it was the highest density
European city outdoing London and Berlin
life was dirty diseased and overcrowded
so in 1922 Le corbisier came up with a
supposed solution
he had designed a new City built for a
modern man and he took the ideals of
that City and imagined a new Paris his
first city attempted to solve four
problems congestion in the center
inefficient density inadequate
transportation and a lack of green open
space
it divides into nine zones a main city
with an intersection of 24 60-story
cruciform Towers a middle section
dedicated to residential space split
between luxury and working-class homes
and of course a green belt separating
industrial as well as Garden cities
but it's important that we look closer
because it's a city designed with an
iron fist
the city is made out of only three
buildings the cruciform skyscraper the
redent and the closed compound
each made to guarantee equal access to
views and sunlight from whichever
position
for the cruciform skyscraper the
serrated shape created traps for light
and the elites who worked there would
receive a better oversight over the
masses that they were privileged enough
to guide
and the other two buildings were
residential built with modular
Apartments ready for mass production
all three meticulously designed and
controlled by a single person
but he went further
some of his buildings were designed with
concrete piles creating a city on stilts
not only did this give access to light
on the ground floors but it also created
his new Transportation Network
he separated traffic into heavy normal
and fast heavy traffic went underground
with a city raised on concrete piles the
underside of buildings could be used
directly as areas for offloading and
onloading
since the ground floor was raised that's
where you'd find normal Goods traffic
including pedestrian walkways and the
last Network concerning fast traffic
would be on raised highways running on a
north-south East and West axis
and all of these roads met at the center
at a multi-story Transportation Hub
which included an aerodome for air
traffic for the planes that landed
between the skyscrapers
and it's this city that was the model
for a new Paris
from the sky we can just begin to
understand the sheer scale of Corby
Shay's plans
Paris has always had a dense network of
roads and inner Courtyards and he
purposely selected the most infectious
neighborhoods the narrowest of streets
to pave over impacting around seven
avondismonts in total
by projecting the skyscraper onto the
same scale section of Paris we can get
an idea of how many buildings the plan
would raise
like Corby Shay's first city Paris would
be divided into zones sector a the
business center containing 18 cruciform
skyscrapers with read-ins for additional
residential space sector B containing
two cruciform skyscrapers as well as a
Central Station that was located
Underground
sector C the residential and
administrative area which is almost
entirely occupied by the sneaking
read-ents of the first city and then
there is sector D containing eight
cruciform skyscrapers
Corby Shay believed that the
introduction of tall buildings would
increase the density of Paris from
around 300 to 1400 inhabitants per acre
while increasing total area Green Space
between the skyscrapers would be triple
floored malls and Subways which would
connect all the skyscrapers with each
other
his goal was to make Paris the world
city of administration
if it wasn't already clear to you it's
probably worth knowing that corbuchet
was kind of a weird man
he created his own entirely new
measurement system based on human length
and the golden ratio he was obsessed
with reinforced concrete and the desire
to put human beings in uniform
standardized cells
and unsurprisingly he had a weird
relationship with his mom and also
fascists which often goes hand in hand
see like the cities he designed
corbuchet believed in a strict
hierarchical and centrally controlled
Society his city was at its core
figuratively and literally one of elite
Administration
the skyscrapers were to be the
headquarters for the captains of
business of Industry a finance of
politics Masters of Science of pedagogy
of thought the spokesman of the heart
the artists poets musicians
who drew up his own pyramid of natural
hierarchies arranging Society with a
technocratic elite at the top to an
increasing bottom of the Lesser skilled
and the top of that pyramid would use
the skyscrapers being able to clearly
examine the world that they commanded
and at the end of the day these Elites
would return to their luxury housing
system in sector C by using of course a
massive elevated Highway running on a
north-south East-West axis
to make his plans more stomachable in
sector a he'd maintain around 14
historical buildings
in sector B around five
and in sector C around seven
if it came true today you'd find a
cathedral next to a gigantic skyscraper
he also tried to dive into finances
according to corbuchet if land values
equaled a and the previous rebuilding of
Paris resulted in an increase of five
times the land value without an increase
in density then surely his plan for
building at a higher density would
result in an increase of four times that
land value
the logic irrefutable
he approached the chief Executives of
major automobile companies who he
thought would support the massive new
streets he had planned and although he
got some to agree with him he didn't get
enough
his plans were considered too radical
and they'd be rejected
that wouldn't stop him
till he died Corby Shay promoted his
vision and world view to other cities
and sometimes he did get his way
including with Brasilia designed by a
student of his
orchanigar in India designed almost
exclusively by Corby Shay
and then there's also the Belmar in the
Netherlands
although it's not designed by corbuchet
it's probably the best example of the
planning he had inspired
and he drew up plans for a lot of other
major cities not just Paris
he had plans for Geneva Berlin and
Bogota
but likely the most insane plan he
proposed was the plan he had for Algiers
the plan obis
it would lead to the construction of a
super highway skyscraper running over a
historical City
with business skyscrapers overshadowing
and hiding the views of the indigenous
it was the line before it wasn't ever
cool
Corby Shay's goal was to make Algiers
the head of the African continent and by
extension France
the story is fascinating which is why
I've made an entirely different video on
it which is exclusively on nebula that
you can watch right now
and once you're there you can then binge
watch some fantastic videos that are
also exclusively on nebula like Neo's
mustard city beautiful and countless
others I love nebula because it allows
me to be more pretentious than I would
be on YouTube without having to perform
algorithm friendly acts like featuring
human faces or caring about what other
people think
nebula also gives you access to classes
where you can watch that dude who makes
Wendover Productions lecture you about
Greek philosophy there are also some
courses on there that I honestly wish I
had seen before I started producing
videos
if you sign up for nebula using the link
below you can get nebula for as little
as a bit over two dollars and fifty
cents a month you'll support me and a
lot of others in being able to buy food
which is really nice but you'll also get
a bunch of other exclusive stuff for
doing that check out go.nebula TV and
get 40 off of an annual subscription